a year ago today i was forced to leave a  job that i loved at the peak of its  success but having the audacity to  express an honestly held opinion well  this shouldn't happen in any democracy  supposedly built on the principles of  free speech and freedom of expression so  i'm delighted to now be returning to  live television with a new primetime  show whose main purpose will be to  cancel the council culture which has  infected societies around the world i  wanted to be a platform for lively  vigorous debate the news making  interviews and that increasingly taboo  three-letter word  fun  i also want it to annoy all the right  people  i'm piers morgan  uncensored